pues si raúl como lo explicaba se ha
roto todas las tradiciones ya lo dijo ya
amenazó que a lo largo del día de hoy va
a hacer diferentes eventos de campaña o
en muy cerquita del pueblo de nación joe
biden para robar este protagonismo a los
demócratas en su último día de
convención y ahora mismo está ofreciendo
una entrevista a la cadena fox en la que
ha dicho que ha visto algunas partes de
la convención demócrata no mucho la
verdad por lo menos sabemos que seguro
que estuvo viendo ayer por la noche el
discurso de barack obama porque durante
el tiempo que el ex presidente daba el
discurso donald trump lanzaba algunos
tuits a través de su cuenta y ha dicho
bueno lo ha presentado el presentador le
ha dicho que si sabe que se está
hablando bastante de él en estos días y
ha dicho pues sí parece que sí es
interesante por esto que decía es porque
se ha saltado todas las tradiciones de
todas formas habrá que esperar a mañana
para ver si realmente su estrategia ha
sufrido efecto no sabemos que ayer 22 8
millones de estadounidenses siguieron la
jornada la tercera jornada de la
convención demócrata a través
televisores mañana podremos ver qué ha
pasado realmente donald trump ha
conseguido su objetivo y también será
muy interesante ver cómo reaccionarán
los demócratas la semana que viene
cuando a la convención republicana dé su
pistoletazo de salida el mismo lunes